>> Greg: YES.
YES.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
MY FRIDAY FRIENDS.
IT'S PRACTICALLY THE WEEKEND.
I CAN ALREADY SEE KAT'S MASCARA
RUNNING DOWN HER FACE.
SPEAKING OF CHILDREN, AS YOU
KNOW, I HATE THEM.
SMALL, GROSS, TOUCHY, STICKY,
SMELLY AND STUPID.
FROM WHAT'S HEARD, CONSTANTLY IN
NEED OF FOOD, WATER AND SHELTER.
THEY'RE LIKE PETS BUT WITH
TUITION.
AND THEY TAKE UP ALL THE BOOSTER
SEATS WHEN I GO TO ARREST
RAUNTSD.
WE ESTABLISHED CHILDREN ARE
DUMB.
SHOULD WE BE MAKING THEM DUMBER?
THAT SEEMS REALLY DUMB.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IN A PIECE
THAT TRASHES EXTENDED SCHOOL
SHUT DOWNS.
WHEN COVID HAD SHUT DOWNS, THEY
SHUT DOWN DISNEY LIKE ON THE TEA
CUPS.
REMOTE INSTRUCTION TOOK OVER.
DISTRICTS MADE THEIR OWN CHOICES
ABOUT OPENING UP.
SOME RESUMED IN PERSON.
OTHERS STAYED CLOSED.
I SHUT DOWN MY WRESTLE
ING I
RAN IN THE ATTIC.
NOW WE CAN COMPARE REMOTE
LEARNING AND IN-PERSON TEACHING.
THE RESULTS ARE IN.
LIKE CNN PLUS, REMOTE LEARNING
[BLEEP] BED.
ACCORDING TO MY RESEARCH, I HAD
MY ASSISTANTS READ OUT LOUD
WHILE I GET A PEDICURE.
STUDENTS THAT ATTENDED SCHOOL
FOR ALL 20-21 LOST 10% OF A
TYPICAL YEAR'S MATH LEARNING.
LUCKY TO THEN, THAT NUMBER MEANS
NOTHING ANYMORE.
SOME STEMMED FROM REMOTE
LEARNING.
OTHERS FROM FAMILY ILLNESS.
STUDENTS THAT STAYED HOME MOST
OF THE TIME FARED WORSE LOSING
50% OF MATH LEARNING DURING THE
TWO-YEAR WINDOW.
ROUGHLY 50%.
IF MY HIGH SCHOOL ALGEBRA HOLDS
UP, IT'S AT LEAST A THIRD.
NOW THE EXPERTS AGREE INPERSON
GOOD, REMOTE SETTING BAD.
OR REMOTE LEARNING MADE IT
HARDER TO CORRUPT CHILDREN.
MAYBE THESE NUMBERS ARE NOT
MEANT TO GET YOUR KIDS BACK IN
TO SCHOOL WHERE THEY CAN BE
FREELY INDOCTRINATED.
YOU THINK OF THAT?
I DID AND IT HURT MY HEAD.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
SCHOOLS MADE BAD STAFFING
CHOICES.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR COMING IN,
DEBORAH.
TELL ME WHY WOULD YOU BE THE
PERFECT CHOICE TO TEACH IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT?
>> AS A NONBINARY PERSON OF
PRIVILEGE, I UNDERSTAND THAT NO
CHILDHOOD IS COMPLETE WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING HOW RACIST YOU
REALLY ARE.
I LOVE TEACHING ART.
I HAVE FOUR MASTERS DEGREES TO
PROVE IT.
THE KIDS COULD HELP ME DESIGN
THE MATCHING NECK TATTOOS THAT I
WANT TO GET WITH ALL FIVE OF MY
PARTNERS.
THEY'RE SEXUAL PARTNERS.
WE HAVE SEX.
GET OVER IT.
>> I'M SOLD.
WELCOME TO OUR SCHOOL.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF YOURSELF.
>> I NEVER AM.
>> Greg: SADLY SCHOOL CLOSURES
HAMMERED LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
BLACK AND LATINO STUDENTS FELL
BEHIND WITH A GAP THAT MIGHT
LAST FOR YEARS.
IT'S A GAP THAT ADMINISTRATORS
CAN'T BLAME OR RACISM ALTHOUGH
THEY'LL TRY.
MAY NOT KNOW THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS FOR YEARS WHEN THE JERKS
RESPONSIBLY HAVE COMFORTABLY
RETIRED ON THEIR MASSIVE
PENSIONS.
HOPEFULLY BY THEN I WILL HAVE
LEFT THE COUNTRY WITH CLIVE
OWEN.
TO CREATE THAT APPLE FARM WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
I WANT TO CALL IT HOW DO YOU
LIKE THEM APPLES?
HE KEEPS CALLING THE COPS.
CLIVE, DON'T.
SO WHO DOES THE TIMES BLAME?
THIS IS AMAZING.
ARE YOU SITTING DOWN?
OF COURSE YOU ARE.
WHO WATCHINGS TV STANDING UP IN
THEIR HOME?
THEY SHOW THAT SCHOOLS WITH LOTS
OF POOR STUDENTS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO GO REMOTE INTENDED TO BE RUN
BY DEMOCRATS OR UNIONIZED
TEACHERS.
MUST HAVE KILLED THE TIMES TO
ADMIT THIS.
THEIR AUTO CORRECT KEPT CHANGING
TEACHER'S UNION TO SEXIST WHITE
MEN OUT OF HABIT.
WE KNEW THIS.
EVERY TIME THEY SAID IT, THEY
CRAPPED ON US LIKE AMBER HEARD
AT THE MACY'S LINEN DEPARTMENT.
THEIR HOME MAY NOT BE CONDUCIVE
TO HOME AS RICHER FAMILIES.
IT'S HARD FOR A 14-YEAR-OLD TO
COOK EGGS AND LEARN.
SO THEY GOT SCREWED BY THOSE
CLAIMED TO BE THEIR SAVIERS.
WE SCREENED ABOUT IT.
IF WE SAID IT IS BAD, THE DEMS
SAY IT GOOD.
SO WAS THIS AVOIDABLE?
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS KNEW
EXTENDED CLOSURES WERE HARMFUL
1 1/2 YEARS BEFORE THEY ACTED.
THEY GAVE INTO TEACHERS THAT
DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO WORK UNLESS
THE ENVIRONMENT WAS 100%
GUARANTEED COVID-FREE.
WE KNEW THAT COVID SPREAD WASN'T
GOOD IN PLACES THAT REMAIN OPEN
VERSUS PLACES THAT WERE CLOSED.
AS THE TIMES NOTE, OFFICIALS
SAID THEY DID SO TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN.
THE AFFECT WAS OFTEN THE
OPPOSITE.
SO ARE YOU SURPRISED?
I'M NOT.
THE SILVER LINING IS THAT WE
LEARNED SOMETHING FROM THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE CAN USE NEXT
TIME ONE HITS, WHICH DR. FAUCI
PREDICTS WILL BE SOMETIME
BETWEEN NOW AND TUESDAY.
WORSE, OUR KIDS WILL BE TOO DUMB
TO REMEMBER WHAT TO DO.
LET'S WELCOME THE KING OF CAMP
AND KNOWS HOW THE VAMP, NEW
AUTHOR, JOHN WATERS.
WE PAY HER TO BE KAT'S BEST
FRIEND.
HOSTING KENNEDY ON FOX BUSINESS,
KENNEDY.
SHE'S THE ONLY VEGAN WHO IS OUT
FOR BLOOD.
DAGEN McDOWELL.
AND LIKE A CANDLE IN THE WIND,
SHE'S THE CAUSE OF MANY HOUSE
FIRES, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT
TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
YOU LOOK FABULOUS.
YOU DON'T AGE BE.
>> YOU BETTER GET YOUR GLASSES
CHECKED.
I'M 76.
I'M NOT MIDDLE AGED.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE 152.
>> Laura: I ALWAYS -- I DON'T
KNOW.
IT'S ALWAYS YOU'RE --
>> OLD CHICKENS MAKE GOOD SOUP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ARE YOU AS WORRIED
ABOUT THE CHILDREN?
I CARE ABOUT CHILDREN AS YOU CAN
TELL.
>> ME TOO.
I WAS IN THE ALVIN THE CHIPMUNK
MOVIE.
I WANT TO BE A TEACHER.
I TRIED TO GO IN.
WHAT I DO, THE FIRST DAY I'D
GIVE THEM ALL RITALIN.
NO MATTER THEIR RACE, I WOULD
TALK IN CLASS.
AND I'D BE CONTROVERSIAL AND
INTO CUES THE DON'T SAY STRAIGHT
CAMPAIGN.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
>> THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT
PLUMBERS, CRACK, MISSIONARY MOW
SITUATION OR THE STATE OF
FLORIDA UNTIL THEY CAN MAKE UP
THEIR OWN MIND.
>> Greg: I'M WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT ANY OF THAT STUFF.
BUT I PREFER CHILDREN NOT TO
TALK AT ALL.
JUST KEPT ON AN ISLAND.
>> KIDS TO ME, BECAUSE I WAS IN
ALVIN THE CHIPMUNK MOVIE, I'M IN
AN AIRPORT.
A CHILD WILL SAY PICK ME UP.
I LOOK LIKE CHESTER THE
MOLESTER.
PICK YOU UP?
OR A PARENT SAYING WHERE IS MY
KID?
IN JOHN WATER'S LAP?
NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: EVEN YOU KNOW YOU'RE A
THREAT, WHICH IS GOOD.
KENNEDY, I WASN'T GOING TO COME
TO YOU.
I DON'TED THINK YOU HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS.
>> IF THEY CLOSED NEW YORK CITY
SCHOOLS AGAIN, I'M GOING TO
PICKET.
NOT JUST MY DAUGHTER'S SCHOOLS
BUT EVERY SCHOOL.
EVERY SCHOOL IN NEW YORK CITY,
I'M GOING TO GET KAT AND DAGEN
AND WHITE CLAWS AND BIG FAT
MARKERS AND WE'RE GOING TO
PROTEST EVERYTHING, THIS IS WHAT
PARENTS HAVE BEEN SAYING SINCE
APRIL OF 2020.
WE'VE BEEN LIKE WHEN ARE YOU
GOING TO GET KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT GOOD.
THOSE OF US THAT COULD SEE OUR
KIDS HAVING A HARD TIME.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT THEY WEREN'T
LEARNING, THEY WERE BEING
MENTALLY TORTURED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
YOU KNOW, ON TOP OF THAT,
THEY'RE BEING TOLD THAT THEY'RE
RACIST PEOPLE AND CAUSE OF THE
DEATH OF PEOPLE IN THEIR FAMILY.
THEREFORE THAT THEY HAVE TO
EXTRICATE THEMSELVES FROM SCHOOL
OR MASK THEMSELVES COMPLETELY OR
THEY'RE GOING TO KILL GRANDMA.
IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT MASKS IS
THE THING WHERE YOU SAW THE
GREATEST LEARNING LOSSES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU MAKE THAT
UP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
THESE KIDS ONCE THEY GET INTO
COLLEGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF COLLEGES ARE
GOING TO HAVE THE PATIENCE TO
WORK THEM BACK IN TO AN ACADEMIC
ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S BAD NEWS FOR AT LEAST FOUR
YEARS OF LEARNING FOR KIDS.
>> Greg: THAT'S THE THING.
CAN -- IS THERE ANY WAY TO
ACTUAL REMEDY THIS, DAGEN, LIKE
A POST -- I DON'T KNOW -- LIKE
MAKE THEM GO TO SCHOOL
>> OH!
>> Greg: YES?
>> THAT'S CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT.
>> Greg: OR BAN SCHOOL.
SCHOOL IS A PRISON, ISN'T IT?
>> WHEN I WENT TO SCHOOL, THEY
DISCOURAGED EVERY INTEREST I
HAD.
I WANTED TO BE THE PUKE KING.
THEY WOULDN'T LET ME.
>> THEY COME OUT WITH THE SAW
DUST AND PUT IT --
>> OR A PRODUCT THAT YOU THROW
TO CLEAN UP PUKE IN THE
CARNIVAL.
IT'S CALLED VOBAN.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO BUY STOCK
IN THAT.
>> CHILDREN WILL RECOVER BECAUSE
SCHOOL IS AWFUL.
I A WEIRDO.
I WANTED TO BE AT SCHOOL WITH MY
DAD'S CHAINSAWS AND PLAYING WITH
GI JOE'S.
GOING TO SCHOOL WAS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I'M A WEIRDO, I LEARNED
TO BE A FUNCTIONAL WEIRDO THAT
COULD EXIST.
I LEARNED TO KEEP MY MOUTH SHUT
SO I WOULDN'T GET POPPED IN THE
FACE.
I DID LEARN A WICKED EYE ROLL SO
I COULD COMMUNICATE WITH MY EYES
OR I LEARNED HOW TO FIGHT IN
CASE YOU HAVE TO GET IN A FIGHT.
ALWAYS GO FOR THE EARS.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> AND I LEARNED THAT DON'T
LIKE -- I LEARNED THAT YOU
SHOULDN'T PICK YOUR NOSE IN
PUBLIC BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE FIND
THAT OFFENSIVE.
MOST.
NOT ALL.
>> I LEARNED ABOUT TRASHY GIRLS.
ONE GIRL IN SCHOOL HAD HER HAIR
PERFECT IN THE FRONT AND THE
BACK WAS A RATTED'S NEST.
WHO CARES WHAT THEY THINK WHEN
I'M LEAVING THE ROOM.
I ONLY WANT THEM TO CARE WHEN I
WALK IN.
>> THAT PERSON'S NAME IS JUDGE
JEANINE.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT IT WAS KAT.
KAT, ANOTHER WONDERFUL TURN AS
DIRT BAG DEB.
>> THANK YOU.
I WANT TO SAY, I THINK YOU'RE ON
TO SOMETHING.
THEY PUT ME ON RITALIN WHEN I
WAS 5 AND I TURNED OUT GREAT.
>> IT'S JUST LIKE DIET PILLS.
IT WORKS.
>> I JUST -- WELCOME TO THE
PARTY TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES," I
GUESS.
LIKE YOU SAID, WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
IT'S NOT JUST ALL OF THE STUDIES
COMING OUT.
TEACHER'S UNIONS SAID THIS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GO
TO WORK.
I SAID THIS MONTHS, MAYBE A YEAR
AGO I KNEW HOW BAD IT WAS, YOU
KNOW, TEACHERS HAD TO BE DOING
SOMETHING REALLY BAD TO GET US
TO START SAYING BAD THINGS ABOUT
TEACHERS.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT A FEW
YEARS AGO WHERE WE WERE -- YOU
CAN'T SAY BAD STUFF ABOUT
TEACHERS.
THEY WERE SELFLESS, AMAZING
HEROS.
BUT THIS IS INSANE.
WE ALL KNEW THIS.
AGAIN, THE HEADLINE IS LIKE NEW
RESEARCH.
OKAY.
THIS IS THE BETTER WORD, LATEST
RESEARCH, IN THE LONG LINE OF
LOTS OF OTHER RESEARCH SHOWING
THAT THIS REALLY HURT KIDS AND
THERE WAS NO REAL BENEFIT IN
TERMS OF STOPPING THE SPREAD OF
COVID.
>> Greg: I STILL THINK THAT
AT-HOME LEARNING LIKE -- I SAID
THE PELETON MODEL.
HAVING CHARISMATIC CELEBRITY
TEACHERS ON A LITTLE MACHINE
JUST SIT THE KID THERE AND
NATIONALIZE IT.
>> YOU SAID THAT ON "THE FIVE"
AND THAT WAS THE BEST IDEAS THAT
I HEARD.
WHAT THEY DID, ALLOWED KIDS TO
TURN OFF THEIR CAMERAS SO THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO SHOW UP.
IT WASN'T JUST TEACHERS.
IT WAS THE TEACHER'S UNION.
THEY ONLY TEACH THREE HOURS A
DAY.
UTLA, THE PRESIDENT OF UTLA SAID
THERE WAS NO LEARNING LOSS.
ALL OF THE UNIONS SHOULD BE
COMPLETELY DISBANNED.
>> A FAMILY MEMBER OF MINE WAS
GETTING YOUTUBE VIDEOS.
THAT WAS PART OF THE AT-HOME
REMOTE LEARNING, WATCH SOME
YOUTUBE VIDEOS A COUPLE HOURS A
WEEK.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT I DO.
>> ON ZOOM, I'M NO PICTURE.
I'M NOT DOING HAIR AND MAKEUP
FOR A PHONE CALL.
HOW PEOPLE HAVE SEX ON ZOOM, I
DON'T KNOW.
THE CAMERA ANGLE, LOOKING UP.
TERRIBLE.
>> ASK JEFFERY TUBIN.
>> Greg: AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
DISINFECT THE KEYBOARD.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: WHERE ARE WE?
UP